now you might think this is not that
tricky right I'm trying to ease you into
this I want you to remember the very
first sight at their back the second
example that we did yesterday was this
guy you don't need to write this down
this is the second example we did we did
10 10 x equals 1 and then we did this
one okay now what was the angle that you
came up with that fit with this do you
remember PI on 3 this time right again
in fact I have a young at the same
triangle yes I want to Jason on
hypotenuse so PI and 3 will do it for me
okay now I'm gonna rewrite this line to
show you where that comes in you chose
plan 3 because cos of Pi 3 is a huff
yeah like that's the same thing cos
inverse was it bad so I can write this
right hand side like so do you agree
with that as a part of 3 it's a lot so
when you see because of something cause
of something else right how will we use
the inverse trig ratios here to help us
write out the answer for this what am I
going to do when I start off with x
equals start me off with quoting the
beginning of the general solution for
anybody
you told me the Florence plus or minus
like you know what usually would we have
here right we would usually write cos
inverse or inverse colors of whatever
that thing is right of that thing here's
the thing alpha in this domain right if
I'm saying alpha is between what's the
domain that I'm interested because
inverse multiplied very good if alpha
has a restriction on that if it's at
least smaller than an obtuse angle is
training then therefore cos inverse of
cos alpha is just gonna hand me back
alpha right so I can just go ahead and
say he X is equal to provided that I
have this restriction on how I'm gonna
write
just as a little note how I written this
same question or with science instead of
cosines it would be very similar to have
the different general solution but
they'll be something different about
domain right it won't be from Mill to PI
what would it be
yeah negative attitude to peyote because
that's the domain I can say that's the
range I'll sign a dose so this here
comes from this guy because that makes
it okay so that's pretty pedestrian
that's not complicated but once you know
this and once you see it you can use
this in all kinds of different ways
right another example okay this is going
to get a little bit stickier now for
starters I mean you'd have to write this
down but this is put to you in sort of
the nicest neatest way possible okay
just like you saw before cause something
close something you can just go straight
into the cosine general solution here
I've got sign something equals sign as
something else now this is been nicely
put I could make this a little bit
harder only a little bit by just
rewriting it like this you don't need to
write this but I just write it like that
number one to show you it okay if I see
that first line where am I gonna go wait
where does my sort of my algebra
trigonometry intuition leads it makes
you cry but I've seen students do this I
know what to do with that I can
factorize okay sign is not a loss but
it's a it's a function right so what
might someone do if they didn't do the
next line what could you do with that
red line what options do you have yeah
you have forty formula if you had a real
idea that caused yourself some pain here
you could okay
you should make you could make a
substitution then go ahead another
suggestion Jesse
I think will do up okay so another way
of seeing is is look at these two angles
here they don't they don't speak a
language that I want there's no I mean
if you were dealing with fractions you
say that their common denominator I need
to get some sort of common denominator
so intrigued terms what I'm going to do
is I could say okay I can say if I
Mexico City is 3x plus 2x and the great
thing at 3x in choices you can use the
same two pieces to get this angle kids
do you see that X take away 2 X now
that's nice but why is it useful what
can I do
following is I can use my dream on
stations right yeah this is gonna be
this guy will be sine 3x plus 2x plus
cos 3x times 2x and then when you do
this guy it's going to be a conjugate
it's gonna cancel that'll be nice okay
so then you can go ahead and solve
that's part number one but I'm gonna try
it but you can go ahead and try and find
that solution later I'm gonna try to go
with this using this first thing I'm
gonna do is I'm going to treat it just
like my other general solutions and I'm
going to say this thing here which I'm
used to seeing an X or a theta or now
for whatever then in this case it's 5x
so I'm solving for 5x right now what's
the general session for signs the last
one we do now I can for a second I have
a general solution but I kind of limp on
this a little bit more because I see
there X is on the left hand side there
are X's on the right I could just divide
through by 5 in got home but it'd be a
little bit weird to have X's in both
spots okay
at the moment it's difficult to try and
get those two together why is it
difficult to combine them anyway so yeah
this guy here for all its brilliance of
taking two different parts of the
equation and boiling them into one
it makes simplifying it very complicated
okay so here's what I'm gonna do and we
need a new line I'm gonna take this and
I'm gonna break it back apart into those
two versions that we had before okay
this is why we're driving the general
solution for sine you need to see if
there are two things that turn into this
okay so here's my own my working you can
continue right along on your page but
really I've got two passes right you're
not got the even multiples of pi and
then I've got the odd multiples of Pi do
you remember that so let's deal with
them one at a time I've got five x
equals let's do the even side first
right when I put even numbers into here
what happens is they didn't want to the
end it just becomes one
so this acts as a plus right so I can
say two and five plus whatever the angle
was which in this case is X okay now you
can see immediately I can do some
simplification at this point right I can
I will in a minute
once I get both of my cases out of the
way okay this is the even case let's do
the odd case how do I buy it how can we
write the podcast
it's a couple of avoiding the way I
think we summarized that was if 2n is
ever even a lot then 2n plus 1 is
everyone normal as we establish before
you could just as equally say 2 n minus
1 that would be fine but I'm just going
to go with this because I like the signs
right so there's all the odd numbers
there's all the odd multiples of Pi from
the even ones we go forward from the odd
ones we go backwards so this should be
takeaway X do you see what I've done so
far if you want you can put a little
long this is not necessary you can put a
subheading ever each one to remind you
what on earth is going on these are all
of the even multiples of Pi and these
are all the on words so no two cases
what now that I have my cases set up I'm
ready to solve these things right let's
take one a time and simplify as far as
we can oh you can what we taught me to
do now I can collect like terms now but
I don't have just we do switching factor
in the middle okay so I'm going to
subtract X from both sides leaving me
with that and now what I'm going to do
so by three cool
so 2 over 4 becomes hmm okay so I'm
gonna put that to one side and now I'm
gonna think about this other side of you
okay
in this case because I've got a negative
a minus X rather on the right hand side
I'm going to add X to both sides which
leaves me with this yeah
and now I just divide through to make X
the subject yeah okay now is this right
how would we know okay before we
establish that um this this is not
actually the solution okay
I'm gonna do something which seems like
it's a little bit backwards like is it
is the point to avoid doing this but
it's actually really helpful for us
this stands for every multiple of pi
divided by 2 right what are those values
one of those actual values if I put in
numbers like 0 1 2 3 4 5 the first
solution of course would be 0 because N
equals 0 is where our unit the origin
right when I put in x equals 1 you're
going to get my on to when you put in N
equals 2 you're gonna get all right then
3.2 then 2 pi and so on yes so this is
the sequence of solutions that I've
generated and of course it also I really
should have dots at the beginning
because they go off into the negatives
as well so here's a lot of solutions
that I get from here what are these
solutions that come from this guy like
well X is going to equal to the 2n plus
1 on the top what kinds of companies
does that give me again it gives me all
the odd numbers right so the very first
one I put n equal 0 in heating the very
first solution I'm gonna get from this
time this is the first odd number on 6
the first odd number of licenses what's
the next number
it's 3
so it's three point six which is PI on -
okay I just pause for a second I have a
solution and it's in business as well as
in business is that a problem
oh there you have a think about it for a
second when we resolve is art like in a
moment what's the next solution this was
um one planet six this is three point
six the next one will be five point six
and it's not together going to be
pretending after that right seven point
six the next one would be 9 PI on six
which is also in my list right okay
actually let's do another one that was
my policy towards the neck another
eleven point six okay now I'm going to
stop okay here's the reason why I'm
putting this one how many solutions do
you count on the board one two three
four five six that one I bought seven
eight nine as a heck of a lot of
solutions why do you think I chose to
stop at eleven pi16 what's special about
that guy it's it's the last one in my
regular life I always see this all the
time domain of north to 2pi line
solutions from naught to 2pi does that
mesh with what I was expecting what I
predicted it's got a picture showing how
many solutions are you predicting I want
you to go right back to the original
line that define this question right and
I want you to pose that question to
yourself here it is what would that look
like
well I assume n was on you're talking
about because I might as well just do
with the form of this generalization
which is about the odd very correct
all right so here's my picture all right
so just pause for a moment is that let
me make it a little easier for you to
read is that what you expected is that
what you expected let me zoom in a
little more so that it's a bit more
helpful for you okay here's the domain
that I am so very used to not to PI
right I know we don't have multiples
apply on our axis that's because it's
just these units but what is 2pi
anywhere to play is six six point two
eight six six point two eight so here's
my one full cycle of regular sine X
right
that blue guy there is sine 5x of course
these sci-fi buttons because how many
copies are there from London to PI
answer one two three four five I can
still count got to give a job okay so
what will we get here
how many times do sine X and sine 5x
intersect
okay now just a second ago I'm not gonna
show you because you've got this listed
we listed out nine solutions right well
let's have a look shall we let's zoom in
a little bit okay I count let me do like
an aim one x equals zero how's the first
solution count it right two three four
firm if I can aim five six seven eight
and I don't think I've written the last
one because I forgot X equals eleven pi
on six that's the wrong color sorry
OCD haha beautiful okay so nine
solutions of course my solutions beside
5x is so periodic he collides with
regular or peaceful sine X that many
times okay oh well yeah okay sorry all
right
you can use your mouse so this is eight
yeah so there's nothing on okay so does
it make sense do you see come went
through and use the regular general
solutions and it gets out like you are
you're fighting two solutions in your
people people who want to do pi you can
find as many solutions as you like
that's all strengths of general social
he doesn't care how many you've got
he'll just get all of them I could just
keep on going and get the rest of this
make sense okay
yeah by the way just as a a bit of
homework I didn't resolve the fact that
two of these solutions came up twice
I'll let you have a think about that why
would they come up twice